good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast today hosting with me I
have my you know protege protege I'm
under her wing slave like [ __ ] Marco
Ashe rice nature Sinatra hello hi thanks
for having me it's like feels like I've
been it's been so long since I've last
been here well since you've last been
here with me well me and you never
really do it together because I'm
covering for you when you're being a
deadbeat you know I'm sorry I've been
fighting that for a while you know Wow
Wow it's like you just think like you're
gonna wake up and do the show and then
you just wake up and gets laid by your
writer you just call me a slave so we're
even now okay
oh my thigh I see it has to be on thigh
duty um the last time you were here we
spent the entire episode talk about
Riverdale cuz I just caught up I know
you don't know penny how like life
changes cuz I don't even watch it
anymore changes it really does change I
know I mean it hasn't changed for me
you're still watching that track it got
so much better it's not like it's not
it's not as like sci-fi II anymore but
you just sit through things you have bad
you have a really hard time saying
things are bad like someone will release
a song or a shell would come out and
Marga was automatically like it's
amazing well cause if it's something
that like I stand I'm not gonna say it's
bad but if it's something I don't stand
I'm the first one to say part of being
this true Stan is like accepting like
that not everything's gonna be great
like I think I'm literally the most
emotionally invested Stan of Taylor
Swift and like I can say that reputation
like wasn't the best you know I can say
reputation wasn't her best but I still
think like it's better it's still better
than Ariana Grande's new album even
though I do this Ariana Grande's problem
is really great but still Taylor's was
always gonna be better I mean I'm not
comparing Taylor to Ariana that's
comparing apples to oranges I'm
comparing Taylor to the better version
of herself which I know she could be
right but she's a Stan it's like I know
she can do her prerogative in releasing
reputation wasn't to put out an amazing
album that was like lyrically genius it
was for her to prove a point
okay point proven can we go back to
gracias she is he told me for those
wondering why jackets not here she is go
into the check
she's gonna get married
well yes Jackie is within 60 days of her
wedding date so she is now eligible to
get her marriage license and that's what
her and Zack are doing this morning
license to Wed they are license to Wed
if you want to check out her Instagram
she looked so cute she was so cute she's
a little Parisian she looked like an ad
for on Bendele yeah she really did
that's what they needed to not go
bankrupt yeah
van Del's not Jackie yeah no that's what
it sounded like
she's not me we're just like all over
the place getting ourselves wedding
ready yesterday we went to dr. Sharon
Jeezy for Botox that's why I just look
so happy right now you know like aren't
I just like gleaming from ear to ear I
need to go too easy
I've never met her I've never been what
I know cuz like I don't know what I
would get Oh cuz you're perfect do you
know but no I think I'm too young to get
Botox yeah you wouldn't have gotten in
at 21 and then crush your eyebrows I do
I kind of would like a nose job
oh stop your butt that's what I'm just
getting crazy you know what you don't
need a notion you just need to brush out
your eyes I said your dimes your
eyebrows are
I know but I'm just waiting until
Jackie's yeah till I get them done but
they're out of control
no they're like their glaze dad like
you're George's oh they're crazy it's
like giving me anxiety every time I look
in the mirror
are you Cara Delevingne no cause hers
like work but here's something
hysterical or whatever live I know when
I was in college I had an internship at
Esquire magazine and it was horrible I
can literally it lasts more than a month
and I was stuck in the closet with like
all the other interns and like they were
just all so happy to be there and like I
was like I don't even like fashion why
am I here and the whole team is just
like unpacking packing unpacking
messenger it was just like never any
torture loging excel and there was this
guy there who was like the head intern I
had intern yeah no and he was like so
passionate about men's fashion like he
is so happy to be here like he had went
out of his way like sent his resume with
his hand-painted envelope and got the
job and I could changed his life and
like he was just like really meant to be
there was like I was just like somehow I
got this somehow got the job and we were
just like talking about celebrities and
like he was like a little bit of a
know-it-all the head intern and we were
talking about Paper Towns is that movie
that yeah
and I was like it was so bad I hate Cara
Delevingne he's like Cara Delevingne its
Cara devolution and they've not I was
like no way sounds like a machine but I
know Cara Delevingne he was like and
every time I say her name I think of
devil gene that is so funny I was just
like you can pretend to know what I'll
hear in this closet cuz like you do but
out here in the real world [ __ ] its
Cara Delevingne no totally I like
literally will never forget that is so
it was the one thing I learned at
Esquire magazine Wow I learned something
that's not true yeah so I've just been
like doing so many like pre-wedding like
aesthetics
you know I'm chubby and something I wish
that I did look you you would know you
never got braces right no it was like
everyone in high school got braces and
it was like a thing but like we did it
even though we both had like buck teeth
and like gap-toothed [ __ ] but braces
wouldn't have made these teeth shorter
you know it's just that my teeth are too
big yeah and like veiny yeah your teeth
are [ __ ] huge here's a bigger [ __ ] I
have more buck teeth you have more fangs
but when you were in high school like
getting braces was like the most social
suicide no and then it was like
bracelets and you uploaded a photo like
in the way you got your braces up I
remember when my friend's got her braces
off and I was like [ __ ] you look better
with braces oh my god but so now it's
like I wish I was going to high school
now it's like there's so many
alternatives nobody has the metal
anymore and it's so much less expensive
like it's not fair you know
I know I was like I know that I'm gonna
be that like older woman who has to like
wear bra says sing but now it's not as
dead like thanks to companies like candy
Co that it's basically invisible which
perfect for me
so candy makes clear aligners that's
what they're called that are sent
directly to your house so you don't have
to leave blessed and they're customized
specifically to straighten your teeth so
the aligners fix fixed crooked teeth
crowding protrusion and gaps so I do
have like a little bit of a gap jackie
has crooked bottom teeth I just think we
could all benefit I really honestly I
kind of really want and like do you have
to wear them all the time or is it I
think you can wear them as much as you
want so the modeling kit retails for $95
you purchased that and then they send it
to your home so you can make the
impressions of your teeth and then they
send it back for like the perfect mold
like what if you just only wear it like
while you're sleeping so nobody knows I
mean
it would just take longer right but you
know what that's not a bad idea bad idea
so you guys can can you get straight
teeth to you one step away from getting
straighter whiter teeth take advantage
of candids risk free modeling kit
guarantee plus when you use our
dedicated link candid co.com slash toast
you'll save 25% on your modeling kit
that's candid koat.com slash toast to
get 25% off your modeling kit candid
co.com slash I might use it now I really
like I'm I feel something I'm just about
my big teeth look you know they're not
big they're just like buck
they're buck and you have a small face
it it's a lot that's why I'm never
smiling with my teeth let me see I
always smile like I look so I can't get
a good smiling face but like that's
usually how I smile with clothes back
when I have a fat face I used to do that
because I could smiling just made my
face bigger right now that I have this
snatched to the gods face I can smile
with my teeth and I prefer it I still
can smile with my I've always been told
to have a beautiful smile really I've
never been actually I've never been told
that once really because people say you
have beautiful eyes I have a Judy
colored eyes nobody said to me but I've
actually been told by many occasions
like I just have like a lovely smile
ready who has a better one podcast
listeners don't know oh [ __ ] so Jackie
usually picks the stories which left me
like with extra work while I was making
my morning to morning Giudice is because
literally I never ate so much my life
today because I drink last night oh
what'd you do last night I'm Hardy with
the kids in college I went to dinner
I forget that here at college I went to
dinner and then the key now one thing
led to another and we went to a bar and
it just got really drunk we like met so
many of these cute guys and like I was
in the heart of Jewishness and Marine
Hill and like the one guy that I hit it
off with wasn't Jewish so it's like oh
my god Margo you never leave your house
let alone you never meet men
the one time we send you out on an
adventure you meet someone who's not
eligible I know is it important to you
to marry someone Jewish you know it's
like it's a it's a but to call a
deal-breaker right for you so like once
I heard that I was like oh I gotta go so
annoying wasted so much time Botox is
supposed to help with migraines and I
really do get terrible migraines but
because I'm so bruised like I kind of
[ __ ] headache headache now yeah
that's annoying because they keep trying
to express myself with my eyebrows um
and dr. easy wouldn't wouldn't allow it
I love her I could spend all day at her
office I think you do I really like she
never comes back every time we leave I'm
like sure like there's nothing else
because I'm CEO Mike easy no you know I
was actually thinking about bringing
bringing co2 dr. keyes yesterday but
then I realize like that's kind of
unsanitary it's like a medical facility
oh that's your like he it's at one point
and animal right as much as we like
refused to believe right and just like
to say that he's human
so by the way I forgot to tell you guys
but you already know Juliet Owens no
Julia Porter I think LC Owens from CS
icky are joining us they will be
arriving shortly and we will hop on like
I just I gotta talk to them I've got a
tomorrow I can't believe it like war is
over war and it's like I never thought
I'd see the day that like I'm actually
like shipping shipping them you know
it's really I was watching less last
week and it's like it's really crazy how
like my alliances can change in like
five minutes
well so I thought that the exact same
thing about Justin Bieber and Haley no I
always like Justin and Haley and then
that by the way we never spoke about it
but that article I'm sure he spoke about
it yesterday I loved it
what you don't watch Esther no I didn't
I actually really meant to because I
wanted to see that but I was just in
class all day but the article made me
like ship them in it and so on it and I
was thinking I'm like either this but I
don't believe that they were celibate
brilliant publicist smooth like yeah you
know like making them look at pathetic
and relatable or like I just misjudged
them maybe both I think a little bit of
both it was definitely like an image
thing but it's also like that I
definitely believe like he has like mage
or demons for sure and like she seems
really like really has it together and
you want to know why it's because she
grew up in a house with a less famous
Baldwin who like really she could
maintain she had like a very normal life
until she was 15 right but she started
trying to be a model right like when she
was like probably like 12 and 13 then
she went to go to like Miley Cyrus
concert like her dad probably be like
got her backstage passes and like she
got cool opportunities like that but
other than that I think she was a
regular gal in public school right
except my dad was a Gossip Girl for a
little bit okay like but that was it but
I don't believe that he was celibate
that was like my only take away and then
also that when she said that she's never
touched a drug
I'm sure she's touched one but she
doesn't seem like a druggie you know but
like she probably smoked pot like with
her friends really I don't think model
smoke pot it makes me oh that is so true
they do cocaine okay
well without further ado it is an
absolute pleasure honor and humbling
experience to deliver the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
okay first from page six Kanye was going
to quote yeah fi that 14 million dollar
miami condo for Kim she no he brought
him yeah but the deal fell through well
he pulled out
here's why residents of the lux
firehouse I didn't realize that's where
I was gonna be in Miami makes me
somewhat relieved that they don't have
to have Kanye West as a neighbor after
all as page six reported West spot a
fourteen million dollar apartment for
his wife Kim Kardashian for Christmas
but then pulled out of the deal now
we're told that one West first visited
the condo he overheard he was overheard
saying then he planned to jfi the place
a reference to his name yay it seems
West wasn't impressed by the energy of
the so-called billionaire beach bunker
which we're told is often used by its
globe-trotting residents for just a
couple months per year Eden so sources
said that the one percent of residents
are quite content with the place in its
onion fide State obsessive as fed
aesthetic no but they said s that like a
shorter version it was that I know like
the noun all right the asset west is
legendary for his adjustments he
masterminded a four-year twenty million
dollar remodel of his Hidden Hills
California home which was reportedly
involved in switching the front and rear
sides of the place he why how do you
know that he also famously took offense
to a bar at his wedding declaring that
it looked like it was from Texas so he
sawed it in half and nailed wood to it
what's wrong with Texas no totally so
apparently they thought he was gonna
like yay it up yeah and go crazy what
I'd like is the lobby and they no longer
wanted him so they're like kind of
relieved they were happy but he pulled
out of the deal I wonder why he pulled
out because Kim didn't want it oh yeah
by the way like she doesn't she doesn't
need an apartment or whatever in Miami
she just doesn't like they don't go to
Miami that much she needs a place in New
York oh they have one sorry they do
kanye does yeah but like no offense to
the people of Miami but like man it's
not really glam it's really not glam I
usually think is so bad and we don't
people have this year and I was like
shell-shocked by like how not go ahead
Scotland eeeh now it's Landa idea like
me but he used to be like very Versace
House glam right now he house glam is
like I consider a trashy no because just
anyone could see their oh really
yeah oh I thought it was exclusive no
it's not so I really don't feel like
Miami is the best branding for Kim I
apologized to the Miami toasters were
probably mad but I'm just saying I'm
sorry you guys still live
gonna be so your evening it's he was
very Calabasas with the K and New York
City yeah totally and honestly I wish it
one of the Kardashians would move to New
York I know but they would never because
like that would just disrupt the whole
this'll be like me moving to LA just
when the celebrities who live in New
York are the most like down-to-earth and
want to remain like have a normal life
like go to Trader Joe's and like not
really be harassed right but if you live
in LA like you're very much here for the
celebrity paparazzi life so in some
other questions because that is was
built on that's who they are yeah did
you see the car DB Harper's was our
story yes did you read it
no very interesting stuff well that's
how the cheese said she had postpartum
she did say she had postpartum but just
like she it was just so interesting also
the article was so well written there's
like a story was like her getting her
nails done in the Bronx and there's like
all the battle coming back to the tech
school it was cool I think you should
prove it I think you'd enjoy it
you read it actually you read like I
read the whole thing what do you think I
do it is okay well moving on ariana
grande blast grammy producer now you're
lying about me she says ariana grande
slams producer Ken Ehrlich for his
explanation as to why she's not
performing on Sunday show in a Twitter
threat on Thursday evening the pop star
26 specifically called out an article
where Erlich was quoted saying she
wasn't able to pull together a
performance in time he basically blamed
her saying she couldn't which is not
true because she's rehearsing for tour
right now for anything she can use one
of those so her she responds was this
I've kept my mouth shut but now you're
lying about me I can pull together our
performance overnight and you know that
Kenan it was when my creativity and
self-expression were stifled by you that
I decided not to attend so she's
nominated for Best Pop solo performance
forgot his women and Best Pop Vocal
album for sweetener she continues I
offered three different songs it's about
collaboration it's about feeling
supported it's about art and honesty not
politics not doing favors or playing
games it's just a game y'all and I'm
sorry but that's not what music is to me
I wonder what they wanted her saying
right so how about that God is a woman
cuz she's nominated for it and she's
like not I'm over it but they also have
had people do medleys like she could
have done a multitude of songs that's
what she was doing but then they wanted
to choose it I mean at the end of the
day I do think you perform the song
you're nominated for and if you can't
agree to that like you shouldn't have
ever agreed to perform yeah yeah because
like the Billboard and all those Bulls
Ward's like that's where people do like
pyrotechnics and dump [ __ ] and play
collabs but the Grammys is all about
collaborating like old and new artists
like having Ariana perform it like
Aretha Franklin if she were still alive
right right or play the song your
nominee for it I got the Oscars there's
five performances it's the songs that
are nominated no I understand the
Grammys is is top tier it's not but they
want to separate themselves from
people's [ __ ] Choice Awards okay
that's fair but I don't know I'm kind of
here for like Taylor and Ariana both
like they got both got chips like what
am i sorry Vocal album Mario oh my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me
what how did it ariana grande get
chipped she was nominated for two albums
for a [ __ ] trash album that could be
real it really was not that bad no it
just wasn't I'm just saying it was like
really the year of ariana grande and
like she didn't get any sure it was
ariana grande and all the song she
released came out after Grammy
nominations came out she next year will
be Ariana Grande's Grammy is fine her
timing was wrong I'm sorry in no way did
she get screwed she was offered to
perform and got nominated for two songs
when her album was bad okay I know you
don't want to say it I love her
sweetener was bad I didn't think it was
that bad why did we listen to it like
four hours but we were on tour [ __ ] we
will listen to anything on tour we're
bored
goodnight and go I mean that's not even
mad you just reference a song that I
added to that song on the album I agree
justice for Imogen Heap
justice very moon oh she's getting those
royalties are you kidding justice bring
Imogen Heap what's the original song
that Imogen Heap
hiding seek
seek I don't know I was gonna sing it as
warz
I'm at it's a crazy song they played it
in the OSI when we were sad I'm yeah
it's such a good song touch me anyway
can you sing it now I can't remember how
it goes okay no I know I remember the
melody I kinda just can't remember the
lyrics hide-and-seek lyrics lyrics sorry
lyrics oh yeah oh yeah crazy okay now I
remember
[Music]
he
[Music]
good stuff it's good stuff motion just
rolling in the royalties that is amazing
man royalties yeah but so I like what
you say
yeah what'd you say what'd you say oh
then Jason Derulo ruined it
yeah I remember but more royalties so
back to ariana grande have it all love
her
the thing about the Grammys is that they
command respect yes they have a museum
but we just consider the Grammys like
Billboard American Music People's Choice
because there's just so many and they're
so many performances that they invite
every [ __ ] singer - where's like you
know what no the Grammy says now
deciding that they're prestigious they
have a museum they have lots of
important they do important work for
music education like let's be real there
they're respectful like you can't just
come and do whatever you want
that's their also I just like to have so
many good feelings about at this year's
Grammys me too there's a lot of like
people I'll be missing out on mainly the
whole Taylor of it all but it over right
Kacey Musgraves like she's been like
doing everything with your any comment
this week which makes me just like think
she's in their good graces just in their
good graces as well as Lu combs and I
need him to win a Grammy like he's he's
a Grammy award-winning artist I just
know it in my heart you know I mean and
he's performing oh my god [ __ ] oh yeah
wait you're gonna know I can be right
here I mean
Annie's presenting we're gonna see so
much of him I'm just like I love him so
much and like I just hope that every one
of the Grammys is nice to him okay oh
man are you kidding he's gonna be he's
honestly oh I'm gonna Instagram him out
interim was amazing he's so funny he
literally he was storing the other day
he just started his tour he's like all
right well show starting soon he's like
it just worked out if you can believe in
him and I hope that like they're like I
feel like a lot of I think that's really
well respected I think a lot of
celebrities are shada Lee from the south
and do like country music yeah so even
though it's really like a pop mainstream
event I think that there are people
there who are gonna be fancy I just like
want to go with him and protect him know
is that matter also he has Kathy and
Nicole and like they're protecting I
want to see what she's gonna wear me to
she posted it like some designer stuff
yesterday yeah she was like I mean I'm
really great fret so you know TBG
invited me to the Grammys
and I have a [ __ ] show and Huntington
which I'm excited for but I'm missing
out on the Grammys honestly like I feel
like that's a good thing just cuz like
well personally I feel like it would be
so overwhelmed no I was gonna say like I
don't think I could handle it yeah
exactly like when he invited me I got a
pit I was like I don't think I could do
it yeah no totally
so it's Betty Ross has nominated for new
artist 12 X Halle okay huh don't know
her is also nominated from of the which
is crazy more easy that was yeah it's
like I just I need it has a country
artist ever won Best New Artist probably
Casey did she did she won that he did
she won Best New Artist yes she did
right and she's so cute in that little
neon cactus dress I don't remember
she really has [ __ ] amazing styling
oh my god where's Mimi oh like that she
has a partnership for sure no she and
she chose wearing Versace Sachi Sachi
like oh I love her I love her I do what
do you think she's gonna sing cuz she
she's not mean for out of the year so
it's really um I feel like slow burn mmm
she did say to me on the red carpet when
I interviewed her that it is her
favorite song I know she's gonna say
that because she said it just like comes
out so easily no but she also like said
it to me you know yeah because I was
talking about that she said I was so
funny
okay did you know that she said I was so
funny yeah I watched it next story I
know would never get chosen by Jackie so
I chose it because I didn't realize I
was sitting next to my fellow Gleek who
what Naya Rivera says there's no beef
with Glee co-star Lea Michele well
obviously not now so there's apparently
no bad blood between Naya Rivera and
former Glee star Lea Michele during
Wednesday's episode of watch happens
live with Andy Cohen where any coming
always answer asks the important
questions Rivera was asked by a caller
about liking Michele's engagement photo
on Instagram as well as well as where
they stand about oh my god sorry this is
a hard question Rivera was asked by a
caller about liking Michele's engagement
post on Instagram as well as about where
the rumored frenemies currently stand
okay that wasn't a real sentence I did
not speak to her but everyone sees
Instagram right Riviera said after host
Andy Cohen said the DoubleTap was like
waving a white flag Riviera said I don't
think there was any beef Riviera got
candid about Michele on her 2016 book
sorry not sorry dreams mistakes and
glowing up this is what she said one of
the Glee writers once said that Lea and
I were like two sides of the same
battery and that about sums us up we are
both strong-willed and competitive not
with each other but with everyone
that's just not a good mixture would be
air a pen LeAnn I definitely weren't the
best of friends and I doubt we'll ever
sit on a couch and eat kale together
again but the rumors of her feud were
blown out of proportion she also wrote
Michelle recently celebrated her
bachelorette party blah blah so I feel
like if in her book we're like you're
gonna be thirsty cuz you want people to
buy it and like after Glee Nayar like
really didn't do it anything else like
she's really clinging on I feel like if
there was I mean she would've been
exploiting it at every cost because like
she'll have to make headlines and it's
what she can cling to so her saying that
really was no beef I actually believe
her you do yeah yeah no I think like
after the whole Cory Monteith of it all
things just came into perspective and
like I think everybody's fine yeah also
like I mean I say this all the time like
not everyone is made to be friends right
and like they were but like trying to be
lean ladies on a show like there's gonna
be some drums I mean one one of them was
trying to be a leading lady one of them
was like the show was the Rachel Berry
show it really should have just been
cauldron army yeah and there was no
competition because there literally was
no competition like it was the Rachel
Maddow Show yeah but she she did get a
bigger role as time was coming on yeah
and by the way she was an importing
character and I'd love Santana lovah so
cute I love Travis and she's so funny
yeah but she was no Lea Michele and she
no I mean just in terms of talent in
terms of talent and just in terms of
like amount of airtime yeah a high
[ __ ] love Lea Michele she's like so
happy with my process with sandy was
Andy and like her she heard em around
Roberts they were all and the girlfriend
privilege they're like best friends
what's her name Josie Joanna Garcia
Swisher yeah they were all in a Maui is
that where they went on her back like
yeah I feel like being able to go to
Hawaii for a bachelorette party
I feel like Lea Michele is like not fun
no no no it looks like a relaxing one
yeah cuz she just like wellness
wednesdays like eats juice she literally
like eats literally leaves yeah like her
wellness one I just make like a broth
with like nothing interesting it's just
her she when she does her wellness
wednesdays on her Instagram that goes
into her fridge and I actually get
surprised I snap yeah it's a big tab I
mean next story I'm really confused
about this
Wendy was from page six and Wendy
Williams is quote super scared she will
lose her show sources said that the book
so basically she's done on the air right
now and accountant seeking over Fido
well I I'm pretty sure to help thing
okay sources said that the beloved
daytime TV host who has been absent from
her
economist syndicated show since December
for a number of reasons is unsettled by
the apparent success of her stand-ins
and she's becoming concerned that she
won't be able to make it back on the air
in time to save her gig that's literally
how I feel every time that you have some
bet on me [ __ ] it's my show get away no
I get that but also you haven't been
gone since December that's a long-ass
time mr. W re-quote she's super scared
in ink no that's not true I was in
Mexico twice what oh sorry never mind I
thought you said you have been here
since ok never ends I quote she's super
scared and anxious as an insider
watching fill-in host Nick Cannon being
a huge hit with her audience is tough
for her they're already starting to mess
with the format it's like watching them
screw around with her baby cannon filled
in for Williams Monday through Wednesday
this week and one positive reviews I
love in the cannon me too actually found
him Spiegel arias and I like that he
stood up for Kevin Hart American Pie
actor Jason Biggs hosted Thursday's
edition of the show and other guest
hosts are booked through February 15th
Wow
the reason for Williams absence are
somewhat murky her family announced in
January that she had been hospitalized
because of complications related to her
Graves disease
she also fractured her shoulder in
December and she hosted her last
appearance on the show wearing a sling
but there have been persistent rumors
that she's also having personal
difficulties involving her husband and
the executive producer of her show Kevin
hunter Williams seemed to address that
issue
oh sorry Williams seemed to address that
issue in a conversation with Nick Cannon
and can and then related to the
program's audience that Williams had
told him that she wanted to speak as a
family unit and her Kevin and their son
little Kevin are all good but for all
her insecurities Williams can't rush
back now to retake the reins as a source
she's in no state to get back to TV
anytime soon we're absurd Williams
didn't respond to multiple requests for
comment wasn't there something with her
husband and a woman yeah no there's just
like a lot of shadiness going on here
and she also fainted on stage remember
that was scary I think that was so scary
I just feel like she she too has demons
you know she too has demons and I like
her show a lot I mean I still am like
really upset with her for what she did
to Lindsay dirty that was like so just
so unfair not cool and I feel like a
little like biased against her but for
the most part I really liked her show
and she's very honest and like she is
friends with celebrities but then also
talk [ __ ] about them and that is hard to
do yeah so I actually really like her
and I think she's refreshing on to
time and I want her show to be
successful but I think it is successful
no it is but like she's not there right
now right so I want her to fight those
demons and get back to work but I also
love Nick Anand he did a post on um hmm
who was it talking about was it Kevin
Spacey I don't know it was on the time
sup movement but it was after something
big happened I believe with Kevin Spacey
and it was just like a real honest thing
he was at Yale and we're all we're all
here now but like we all knew yeah and
like let us take some responsibility for
the fact like we worked in an industry
and worked for producers who we knew
were bad people yeah and he said he took
myself included like well he's taking
responsibility and then someone said
something like you know it kind of felt
like he might have something coming out
like this is like a PR move and there's
nothing about no nothing came out but
that put like a little pit inside my
stomach but for the most part he was
like a really honest candid take on the
whole thing and I really appreciated it
oh I actually really liked him by the
way are you gonna watch the Kelly
Clarkson talk show of course I love her
of course
you know why I love Nick Cannon cuz he
takes any [ __ ] job they give him and
does his best like that [ __ ] is the
host of super gameshow don't know singer
but it's the biggest show it's so stupid
so she never watched it but I know it's
stupid look every time it gets unmasked
just cuz like you know I'm curious yeah
and it's like it's never anyone that I
like it's narrow of course I don't
recognize the voice I don't know the
person right and they supposed to be
singers I don't know I don't understand
like whatever we have one more story
that's it I know I'm kind of like I
can't even remember together 30 minute
when did we do whatever before we do
what taste episodes morning toast is
brought to you by Skillshare Skillshare
is an online learning community for
creators with more than 25 thousand
classes in design business and more
you'll discover countless ways to fill
your curiosity creativity and career
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography
creative writing or even illustration
Margo this sounds like 70 times more
useful than your actual college degree
totally whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
skills shares there to help you learn
and thrive
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners you
can get two months of Skillshare for
free that's right Skillshare is offering
the morning toast listeners two months
of unlimited access to over 25,000
classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
morning toast
again that's Skillshare comm slash
morning toast to start your two months
now Skillshare comm slash morning it's
actually so smart yeah if you should
want to learn some mobile photography
that's like struggle mobile photography
no also well I was actually in a
creative writing class but I am because
there's way too much in real school yeah
like it was like eight to ten short
stories eight to 10 page short stories
like once a week gonna be back created
10 pages is not a short story final
story some positive news Adam is just a
terrible tumultuous story Hacienda
health care too close after an
incapacitated patient gave birth so a
nurse that Ozzie and health care was
arrested and charged with sexually
assaulting a patient but the Arizona
long-term care facility where incapacity
to patient was sexually assaulted and
gave birth will be closed the company
said Thursday Hasina Health Care's Board
of Directors quote has come to an
understand that it is simply not
sustainable to continue to operate our
intermediate care facility for the
intellectually disabled the company said
in a statement it is a skilled nursing
facility that will stay open for mer
nurse at Ostia end of health Nathan
Sutherland 36 was arrested January 22nd
in charged with sexual assault
he has since pleaded not guilty lol the
case came to light in late December
after a 29 year-old woman who has been a
patient at ASEAN de for years went into
labor and gave birth as already said so
at first when I read this I'm like yay
like in justices will be right but then
at the same time like there are patients
there who rely on that facility and the
case makes me think that if their go-to
was to close the facility that's
something that we don't work out totally
weird cuz like like I it's fishy no like
if that was like the response you know
definitely like a lot of families
whether I'm sure they'll relocate that I
know but it's just like they're already
going through enough with having someone
in like long-term like care facility
like you know they have to up and move
like it's torture ya know it's I feel
like it's a little weird that they chose
to shut it - no you're right it must be
like really [ __ ] bad yeah like
there's a hundred percent something that
we do not know and honestly I want to
know if the story in them itself gives
me a pen like honestly Nathan Sutherland
deserves to rot in prison literally I
can't believe like said he's not guilty
like hiding in evidence
yeah there's a baby but did he say for a
reason like for mentally ill or whatever
I don't know nor do I care
he's guilty yeah that place just seems
like a cesspool of sadness
like I'm happy that it's gone but like
there are so many facilities like that
like I mean it's always happening in SVU
so I know that by the way that's really
it's like an SVU episode yeah they're
gonna do it for sure I think they
already
they always recreate like always
recreate like things that have happened
in in the world now that I'm done with
the stories I finally tune into the feed
and you are looking slim honey with that
thigh Wow thank you oh my god I got
dressed in two seconds this morning I
like by the way what time did you wake
up to it like what time do you wake up
when you have to do that I was like put
on makeup so I try and get here like
10:15 right I have about a 20-minute
commute right so leave my house like
9:45 so you wake up at I set my alarm at
8:30 and I get out of bed at 9:00 okay
well so I tried to wake up at 8:45 today
and I like I snoozed like stuff till
9:15 8:45 to 9:00 15 yeah that's normal
waking up at 9:15 I thought it was so
late 19 I was like oh you have to get up
yeah begin big plans no I like could but
I don't want to join me yeah plus we
have week shows okay so we've chosen
Huntington first one is sold out but I
did I had like 30 tickets reserved for
myself because I thought I had a lot of
friends and family coming but I didn't
so I released them back for sale so if
you do go to the website you might be
able to get tickets to the eight o'clock
show but there are still tickets up at
the four o'clock show unfortunately
nobody empty tickets and then also I
meant to tell you guys yesterday we did
presale for the second Irvine show third
Houston show today I will do cell for
everyone so check my Instagram stories
for the link hopefully they'll sell out
- they'll be so epic but had to grow
closer calm going all over the country
we got Florida coming up Foxwoods I
think I'm adding another show and
Foxwoods we got Dallas we got Hughes him
I got vine we've got brea where else
Tampa Greensboro Baltimore in bail yeah
I'm actually really excited for
Greensboro Greensville leg for one
reason only live tell me so we're doing
two shows the day we land in one of them
I get them confused it's North Carolina
South Carolina they're right next to
each other I don't know I don't know
which one is which but they both have
the same name I want to say Greensboro
we land in Greensboro we do a show today
I don't know I know just one and then we
drive that night to Greenville or
whatever they like a nice Drive because
it's a long commute and we're on tour
I got us like a mini tour bus like a
little sprinter but I'm excited and it's
gonna be like glam with are we gonna
family channels again yeah we're gonna
be like rich I'm gonna film a music
video in there
looks like a soft money make our DNA
okay just be like yeah yeah yeah like
fake money
let's just get like a hundred dollars in
singles and okay but then go back to the
Baker like at the hunter dollars back
pick them up off the floor and make sure
we don't miss a ballet so I we've been
on tour for quite a minute I know my
short leg in January which was like so
successful for me like just creatively
it was it was her about her best like
yet but yeah like she's escaped I
started off in Columbus or one or
Cincinnati I forget which is Cincinnati
and just like did a great show after not
being on the road for a while and like
was really confident and like usually
when I do a good jail like Anna you can
only go downhill from there and then
like Columbus like I did even better and
then [ __ ] it in Detroit hit it out of
the park I think Detroit was crazy
ya know Detroit was so awesome I love
doing theater it's like saying comedy
clubs make me feel so much more relaxed
and like I really get to like practice
my craft and then the mean greets are
like really intimate and the green which
I love yeah there's a club food is the
shape the shape they've such good fries
but I mean there's nothing like walking
out onto a theater that like literally
like actual famous people have been on
like it feels awesome
personally I like theatres because like
makes my job so much easier they have
their [ __ ] together all I got to do so
this weekend when we go to the Paramount
Theatre in Huntington I went there for a
concert to see Kacey Musgraves like two
albums ago really yeah so like it's a
real place the contest was just there
there's nothing like walking on stage in
a theater like that makes me feel like a
big big Musgraves saying on to stay
every time I go to a venue Casey's been
I like sniff the couch in the dressing
room know when we were in Detroit
because she had been there one of the
day before like we were sitting on the
couch and we were like do you think he
like sat here and let me found out that
there was a much bigger green room right
next door that was where she probably
hung out that I did do a nice thing for
you and I did get us to Kacey Musgraves
tickets and meet and greets me angry I
think I was in Dallas welcome are there
an extra day I meant to tell everyone I
meant to tell you this so Kacey
Musgraves I had like since become like
just obsessed with her tour and I met
her manager and her manager has had to
do something really nice for us I have
now the opportunity to give away to
Kacey Musgraves tickets to the Dallas
and Nashville shows they asked me if I
wanted to do a giveaway and I said sure
don't like which shows I'm like what are
toasty cities Dallas and yes they're
gonna be at the Dallas one so I I'm not
figuring I'm not sure yet how do you uh
enter the giveaway but I just wanna let
you guys know I
get away two tickets to the Dallas and
two tickets to the Nashville show just
because I thought that would be cool
every way four tickets in total yeah and
they said the show we're gonna be at Wow
wow that is so nice of you
yeah no I'm excited I'm also excited to
talk to Kelsey and Julia so let's let's
do that
okay so Juliet Porter Kelsey Owens wars
over siesta key I'll recap this week's
episode cuz me and Jackie action in
recap it but we'll also ask because I
know I think Juliet now it's a broken up
there's a lot going on since the last
time I saw Juliet which was literally
one week ago so if you're on the YouTube
stream feel free to leave a comment for
them also if you're not go to the
Instagram leave a comment there there
were a lot of questions there we'll pull
from there we'll be back in about two
minutes go to the bathroom get a snack
to pick your nose pick your wedgie do
what you got to do it we'll see you in
five minutes bye